[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est Paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux l'image de ce paléogneux c'est
évidemment celle-ci d'un cléostheus qui
en février 2023 donc le mois dernier a
pris un grand coup de jeune et à rétréci
au lavage voyez les estimations de
taille de notre poisson cuirassé préféré
d'un Cleo stéus passe de 8 à 10 mètres à
seulement trois quatre mètres il a
sérieusement rétrécié au lavage alors
est-ce que c'est dû à la lessive qu'ils
utilisaient au Démonia je ne crois pas
c'est dû en fait à cet article un
article qui a été publié dans la revue
Dyer City par le chercheur Russell
Engelman et dans cet article en fait il
refait une estimation de taille de notre
poisson cuirassé préféré d'incléostéus
voilà il y a une petite reconstruction
de d'incléostéus ici si jamais vous ne
vous rappeliez pas à il ressemblait et
la chose qui me semble être la plus
importante dans cet article c'est pas
tellement comment Angelman est arrivé à
cette à cette taille de trois quatre
mètres pour d'incler osteus alors
regardez la très belle photo de ce qu'on
connaît de d'un cléostheus et c'est bon
de le rappeler parce que d'un Clio s'en
a pas de fossile complet on a juste la
tête la tête et la ceinture comme vous
voyez la ceinture scapulaire donc le
bouclier crânien et le bouclier nuccal
normalement tel qu'on devrait l'appeler
donc d'un coléostéus on en connait que
la tête et on n'a pas le corps entier
donc les en fait le corps entier la
longueur du corps ne peut être que
estimer
et c'est ça si vous avez vu notre vidéo
sur Brachiosaurus et quel est le plus
long le plus gros dinosaure du monde
vous savez que les estimations de taille
quand il s'agit de fossiles ça peut
aller de très carré et très bien et très
bien fait à pifomètre total ben
justement
ce qu'il y a de très intéressant dans
cet article de Engelman c'est son
tableau numéro 7 son tableau numéro 7
qui fait un résumé de toutes les tailles
de dingléostéus qui tel qu'elles ont pu
être proposées dans la littérature donc
vous avez auteur de l'estimation de
taille vous avez l'estimation de taille
en elle-même en mètre ou en pied alors
si vous êtes américain et que vous avez
décidé de mesurer votre camping et ici
vous avez surtout la méthode qui a été
utilisée donc là par exemple Newberry a
proposé une taille de 4 mètres à 5
mètres 50 en prenant le fossile complet
du cousin de dakhléostéus qui s'appelle
kokosteus que je peux vous montrer un
petit peu plus tard donc on a un fossile
complet de cocostéus qui est un aussi un
Placoderme comme d'un Cléo ostéus on le
prend on fait une mesure de de du crâne
de cocostéus on fait une mesure de la
longueur complète de cocostéus on fait
une mesure de la longueur du crâne de
d'un Clio ostéus on fait un produit en
croix et ça doit nous donner la longueur
de d'un Clio ostéus
ça semble raisonnable c'est un c'est
juste un bête produit en croix mais ça
semble raisonnable et ça vous donne donc
une longueur de 4 mètres 50 à 5 mètres
ce qui est pas mal parce que ce qui fait
un beau poisson mais ce qui est déjà pas
les 8 10 mètres qu'on peut entendre
parfois dans les documentaires et qu'on
peut lire parfois dans la littérature et
donc ce qu'il y a de très intéressant
avec ce tableau numéro 5 avec ce tableau
numéro 7 que Engelman nous propose c'est
qu'en fait on se rend compte que toutes
les estimations de taille qui dépassent
les 5 6 m ça a été fait au pif enfin la
méthode vous voyez unstate alors ça a
été ça veut dire non expliquer ça veut
dire qu'ils n'ont pas expliqué comment
ils ont atteint cette estimation c'est
un euphémisme pour dire pifomètre
et on vous avez des grandes autorités
telles que
tels que rumeurs Alfred Romer tel que
Colbert Colbert Colbert de Molière
évidemment mais enfin pas Colbert de
Louis XIV mais Colbert Colbert
paléontologue américain donc vous avez
des grandes autorités qui a un moment
ont décidé 9 mètres mais qui explique
jamais comment ils atteignent cette
cette estimation
la chose étant que en fait ils y sont
allés au pifomètre donc 9 mètres c'est
du pifomètre ici vous avez une taille de
8 mètres cité à partir de Donaldson ah
bah là peut-être là au moins ils
expliquent que ah mais moi je l'ai pris
de quelqu'un d'autre ouais sauf que
Denison quand vous le regardez il a dit
6 mètres
il a pas dit 8 mètres prenez 8 mètres 79
ça c'est très précis périmètre de la
mâchoire va là au moins on a un truc
périmètre de la mâchoire mais on n'en
sait pas plus probablement encore une
histoire de produits en croix là 6 à 8
mètres pas expliqué 7 mètres 7 mètres 1
pas expliqué
donc vous voyez dès qu'on a la 10 mètres
pas expliqué dès qu'on a une estimation
de taille qui est outrageusement grande
pas expliquer s'y mettre cette pas
expliqué donc la seule la seule mesure
de taille qui est pas trop mauvaise
enfin qui est
techniquement pas trop mauvaise c'est
celle là et qui dépasse les 8 mètres
voilà c'est ferronetal avec leur 8
mètres 79 et c'est marre donc ce qu'il
faut retenir déjà de la première chose
qu'il faut retenir à mon avis de ce
papier de Engelman c'est que si ça vous
emmerde que ta cleosteus soit tout petit
faut bien vous faire à l'idée que en
fait d'un cléos d'un Cléo stéus est tout
petit à chaque fois qu'on essaye de mes
d'estimer sa longueur de façon bien
gigantesque que si on y va au pifomètre
bizarre non
et donc Engelman rajoute sa pierre à
cette édifice en disant bah nous on va
essayer de proposer une estimation de
taille qui tient la route
pareil alors pas à base de produits en
croix mais c'est à base de régression
linéaire ce qui est un produit en croix
ce qui est une façon de faire en fait un
produit en croix mais sur des dizaines
voire des centaines de spécimens à la
fois donc une régression linéaire ça
n'est rien que ça donc ce qu'a fait
Angelman c'est qu'ils ont remarqué que
chez les poissons modernes et chez les
fossiles aussi la longueur du corps est
toujours extrêmement proportionnelle à
la longueur de la tête si vous prenez
aussi l'opercule dans la taille de la
tête donc ce qui trouve c'est cette
fonction linéaire là que je vais vous
montrer maintenant ici
donc il trouve cette fonction linéaire
totale longueur totale du corps sur la
longueur entre l'orbite et l'opercule
donc c'est une mesure de la longueur de
la tête vous commencez à l'orbite vous
allez jusqu'à l'opercule c'est c'est une
mesure de la longueur de la tête ça n'a
rien de et ça exclut en fait si vous
excluez ce qui est à l'avant de l'orbite
en fait vous excluez évidemment vous
allez vous allez avoir cette partie à
l'avant de l'orbite qui va être très
adapté à la façon dont l'animal en fait
attrape sa nourriture ça va être la
partie la plus malléable du crâne j'ai
envie de dire donc c'est vraiment la
partie entre l'orbite et l'opercule que
vous voulez qui est la partie la plus
conservée qui est la moins adaptative on
va dire donc cette partie entre l'orbite
et l'opercule c'est la mesure du crâne
qu'ils ont utilisés ils exclu du coup le
rostre qui est la partie qui va être la
plus malléable et qui va être la plus
qui va changer en fait en fonction du
régime alimentaire
et en faisant ça il trouve une
régression linéaire ici donc comme je
vous l'ai dit c'est une façon très
compliquée enfin c'est une fraction très
technique de faire un produit en croix
en ayant là vous voyez des centaines de
d'entrée en fait vous pouvez pas faire
un produit en croix avec des centaines
d'entrée mais vous pouvez faire une
régression linéaire c'est le même
principe et donc sur cette régression
linéaire ce qu'il faut voir en fait
c'est que vous avez la ligne qui passe
au milieu et vous avez les points qui
sont chaque poisson qu'ils ont mesuré
dont ils ont mesuré la taille de
l'orbite à l'opercule et la longueur
totale et vous voyez qu'en fait les
points sont très resserrés autour de
cette régression linéaire ce qui veut
dire que cette régression linéaire
mesdames et messieurs est très puissante
il y a très très peu de il y a très très
peu de poissons la ligne c'est la règle
et quand vous vous éloignez de la ligne
vous êtes une exception vous voyez il y
a très très peu de trucs qu'on pourrait
appeler des exceptions
donc ça c'est c'est déjà il faut
souligner la première chose c'est la
puissance de la méthode qu'ils ont
utilisé la statistiquement c'est du
caviar on voit r carré qui a
94,7 %
94,7 % ou
0,947 c'est ça que ça veut dire donc le
r carré ça veut dire à quel point
justement la courbe est prédictive donc
la courbe est prédictive en gros à 95%.
c'est vous n'avez que 5% de chance de
faire des erreurs c'est donc une courbe
très puissante et donc appliquée d'un
Cléo stéus donc en mesurant la taille la
dimension vous voyez là la dimension de
l'orbite à l'opercule et en
reconstituant la taille du corps grâce à
cette régression linéaire en utilisant
l'équation de cette régression linéaire
qui marche donc comme un produit en
croix et bien on arrive à un
d'inclerostéus mesdames et messieurs
qui mesure la taille de 3,5 à 4,5 m les
plus gros spécimens auraient atteint 4,5
m et donc quand on fait une
reconstruction de ceux d'un cleosteus à
3,5 m donc par rapport à la taille du
crâne on voit que les proportions
comparées à cocostetus sont assez
conservés donc là on n'est pas à
l'échelle attention on n'est pas à
l'échelle on fait des mesures de
proportion donc cocoteus il fait que 1 m
de long là faut imaginer que d'un
cléostheus il fait 3 4 mètres de long
ils le ont remis à l'échelle pour
pouvoir comparer les proportions et donc
ce qu'on constate c'est que quand on met
d'un cléostheus à l'échelle cette
nouvelle reconstruction de dingléostéus
à l'échelle bah il a des proportions qui
sont relativement bien
conservé par rapport à son cousin
co-costéus dont on a les fossiles
complets par ailleurs
c'est ça qui est important c'est
d'obtenir un résultat qui est cohérent
et là on a du coup une méthode qui est
très puissante et un résultat qui est
très cohérent et du coup il y a pas de
raison de considérer que cette mesure
que cette nouvelle estimation de taille
de d'incléostéus soit mauvaise et elle
est d'autant plus puissante d'autant
plus cohérente cette taille qu'en fait
quand on regarde la littérature qui a
été publiée avant on constate que tous
les gens ou presque la quasi-totalité
des gens qui ont donné des tailles des
mesures de taille gigantesque pour
d'incléostéus ils ont fait ça à la zone
et que tous les gens qui se sont arrêtés
pour faire des mesures à peu près
correctes ou presque on finit sur des
mesures qui étaient plus beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus modeste donc notamment
Newberry notamment on a vu tout à
l'heure feronettal qui mesure une taille
maximum de 8 mètres 79 mais à côté de ça
la taille moyenne ils l'ont trouvé à 6
mètres 88 donc c'est pas non plus un
c'est pas non plus de la folie furieuse
donc vous voyez c'est un c'est quand
même un article qui je pense a beaucoup
beaucoup de mérites alors évidemment ils
vont discuter pourquoi il y a cette
relation en fait entre la taille de
l'opercule et
la taille du corps donc ce qui est
probablement un gradient de
développement le développement
finalement ce commence avec la tête et
après ce c'est un gradient qui va se
développer dans le corps mais bon ça
c'est de la génétique on va pas trop
s'arrêter là dessus mais c'est
intéressant c'est discuter dans
l'article
et donc ce qu'il y a ce qu'ils disent
c'est qu'en fait on n'a pas de preuve en
fait que les vertébrés avaient dépassé
la taille de 5 mètres avant le
Carbonifère et ça du coup écologiquement
ça a beaucoup beaucoup d'implication
quoi de ça veut dire que au Carbonifère
là c'est très bien représenté par cette
image au Carbonifère il y a pas de
prédateur marin qui dépassent la taille
d'un grand requin blanc
et ça du coup sur la structuration des
écosystèmes avant le Carbonifère pas au
Carbonifère pardon sur la structure des
écosystèmes avant le Carbonifère donc
pendant le Démonia notamment ça son
importance ça son importance parce que
d'un cléostu à 10 mètres de long c'est
un méga prédateur d'un clé ostéus enfin
c'est un TOP prédateur c'est un
prédateur de prédateurs
à 3 ou 4 mètres de long au Démonia c'est
un prédateur vous avez des cette
stratification en fait de
l'environnement avec des prédateurs qui
mangent des proies qui sont herbivores
et qui elle-même mange de la du coup des
producteurs primaires de la végétation
et on s'est proies vont être mangés par
des prédateurs et dans les mers vous
avez souvent au moins deux strates de
prédateurs par dessus ça donc des
prédateurs de prédateurs et des
prédateurs de prédateurs de prédateurs
et bah ça veut dire que d'un clos tus il
était pas tout là-haut
pour dire les choses de façon globale de
façon simple donc ça a des implications
sur la reconstitution des écosses des
écosystèmes du dévonia mais ça nous dit
Engelman ce sera pour un prochain
article les implications ils en
discutera sur un prochain article on
continue avec maintenant le pro pâtadium
des dinosaures et notamment des
dinosaures Maniraptoriens les plus
proches enfin en tout cas parmi les
dinosaures non-aviens le plus proche des
oiseaux mais les manières raptoriens
inclut aussi évidemment les oiseaux et
d'après cette étude publiée dans The
logical letters par deux chercheurs
japonais de l'Université de Tokyo tous
vos Raptors sont faux tous c'est d'où le
titre de cette vidéo les valéo-artistes
en PLS vous n'avez quasiment jamais vu
une reconstitution une reconstitution de
Raptor correct pourquoi
parce que toute néglige le propaggium
pro patagium donc le protagium c'est un
petit bout de membrane qui existe chez
les oiseaux et qui s'étend de l'épaule
jusque jusqu'à la jusqu'à l'articulation
ici du poignet donc c'est la pro le
propagéum qui à l'opposé du patagium le
patagium il s'étend normalement du
poignet jusqu'à la jambe c'est ce qu'on
voit chez les chauves-souris par exemple
les oiseaux n'ont pas de patagium par
contre les oiseaux ont un gros patagium
c'est-à-dire cette membrane qui part du
poignet jusqu'à l'épaule tous les
oiseaux de long et donc d'après les
fossiles et d'après cette étude très
exhaustive faite par des chercheurs
japonais en fait les gens ont eu un peu
tendance à négliger ce que vous voyez là
vous voyez cette petite race Brune ici
et cette petite trace brune là bah c'est
le propagéum fossilisé ici sur un beau
fossile de micro Raptor
il est là depuis toujours et les gens le
regardent pas
donc en fait toutes les reconstitutions
que vous avez pu voir de
vélociraptor ou de n'importe quel Raptor
où vous voyez le creux du coude parce
que normalement le propaga il le
recouvre le creux du coude donc toutes
les reconstitutions que vous avez dans
la littérature sur internet à la télé au
cinéma où vous voyez le creux du coude
de votre vélociraptor bah c'est
reconstitutions sont fausses le j'ai
trouvé le meilleur moyen de caser un
bras d'honneur sur une vidéo je crois
l'excuse la plus Ballo pour bon bref
donc ouais on a tout donc du regardez
regardez c'est bien c'est maintenant
vous pouvez être attentif et vous
regardez même préhistorique planète je
suis pas sûr pourtant j'ai chanté les
louanges de préhistorique planète il y a
sur certaines snapchat du coup je suis
allé voir des snapshots je suis pas
retourné voir le documentaire entier
mais je suis retourné voir des snapshots
des screenshots du documentaire
préhistorique planète
c'est pas ils sont pas toutes hyper
convaincants alors je retournerai voir
quand on va voir sachant qu'ils vont
sortir une saison 2 je verrai bien dans
la saison 2 si d'ailleurs ça fait partie
des Paléo news aussi il va y avoir une
saison 2 de préhistoric Planet
mais
on verra bien dans la saison 2
d'ailleurs si ils inclut le propager ou
pas je suis curieux mais je retournerai
voir aussi la saison 1 pour voir si le
propager homme était déjà là ou pas mais
même eux voyez je suis pas sûr donc ça
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt cool en fait
de voir c'était là c'était sous nos yeux
je veux dire il y a pas de il y a pas de
doute sur l'interprétation de ce petit
bout de de tissu mou là qui est préservé
ici hein c'est définitivement le
propagerum sauf que bon bah tout le
monde l'avait zappé personne l'a vu s'il
y a que maintenant qu'on ah bah merde en
fait il a été il était là depuis le
début c'est des fossiles qu'on a
découvert depuis des années 90 donc
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ce propagerum
chez les oiseaux bah il y a surtout une
membrane de peau vous voyez il y a un
trou quand on dit sec il y a un trou
donc ça c'est couvert par une membrane
de mais il y a aussi des tendons et il y
a notamment un tendon qui va se relier
au muscles propagage yaliste donc le
muscle du propaga qui aide le bras à se
replier et alors ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que certes on a
préservation des tissus mous qui
permettent de voir directement ce
propagerium mais du coup vu que le
propageum
étendu du poignet jusqu'à l'épaule bah
en fait les fossiles qui possèdent les
fossiles des animaux qui possèdent un
protagium quand ils vont se fossiliser
ils vont spontanément fossilisés avec le
bras qui se replie comme ça donc ce
qu'on voit ici avec avec le micro Raptor
le bras vous voyez il est pas resté en
extension il est replié parce que le
muscle du propagéum en fait c'est
contracté pendant la pendant la mort
c'est la contraction post mortem pas des
ligaments postérieurs du coup dans ce
cas là mais du ligament de du muscle
propager propagage et Alice
donc la contraction peut se porter une
des muscles c'est quelque chose
d'universel dans le corps entier ça
concerne aussi le muscle du potagerum et
donc il suffit de regarder l'angle que
fait ici le lumérus avec le rat du sudna
pour voir si il y a eu oui ou non
contraction du muscle propagéalisme post
mortem même sur les fossiles qui ne
préservent pas de propager homme et
grâce à ça on peut reconstituer une
distribution du propaga représenté sur
les branches de cet arbre phylogénétique
en blanc et j'ai une version simplifiée
de cet arbre je vous la montre
immédiatement
voilà la version simplifiée de cet arbre
la voici donc vous avez évidemment les
oiseaux qui ont les oiseaux modernes qui
ont un gros patagium et donc le
propagéum on constate qu'il est présent
chez les tous premiers oiseaux comme
archéoptérix et jusqu'à Kodi terryx donc
ce qui veut dire que tous les manies
raptorales ont un gros patagium y
compris les gros du coup y compris des
gros machins comme
Uthar Raptor et teriziosaurus il y a des
gros machins qui avaient à propaga les
terres dinosaures avaient eux aussi un
gros potageraptor les oviraptory d
avaient aussi un gros potager y compris
les oviraptors les oviraptori des géants
donc en fait le propagéum n'est pas une
adaptation au vol
façon qu'on les qu'on les oiseaux
regardez ça se voit très bien ici vous
voyez l'oiseau comment il replie sa main
et vous voyez ici hop le micro Raptor
commence sa mère est replier donc c'est
probablement lié à la présence de cet
osse ce millénaire bien que je ne puisse
pas vous dire à l'heure actuelle en quoi
les deux sont reliés on a mis en a mis
en PLS les appâts Léo artistes
maintenant c'est l'heure de briser vos
rêves une nouvelle étude communiquée
dans la prestigieuse revue communication
biology enfin pas encore prestigieuse
communication biology mais comme c'est
nicher qui vient de la Lancer on est à
peu près sûr qu'elle va devenir
prestigieuse dans pas longtemps
c'est une étude qui s'intéresse aux
griffes des Théropodes et notamment
celle des terresinosaures et des
alvaraisses odides parce que les griffes
des terres dinosaures et les
alpesaurides elles sont graves chelou
c'est terrible dinosaure et ses Alva
resorites qui sont vraiment à deux
extrémités d'un continuum de diversité
de taille de griffes extrême avec les
donc les alvaraisorides qui ont les plus
dérivés aucune griffe au bout des doigts
une grosse griffe au bout des doigts
supposément pour creuser les termitières
et se nourrir de termites ce que cet
article soutient d'ailleurs et vous avez
de l'autre côté des therizinosaures qui
ont donc trois doigts techniquement
c'est un deux trois et pas non et passer
3 là 1 2 3 donc c'était donc 2 3 4 en
l'occurrence donc vous avez les terrains
dinosaures qui ont donc trois doigts
avec des immenses griffes et les plus
grandes étanches et par exemple
terizinosaurus et là pareil on sait là
on sait pas trop à quoi elle servait ça
on a buté sur ce problème là plus d'une
fois d'ailleurs si vous vous rappelez
les les game Paléo react c'est un truc
c'est une question qui revient très
souvent dès qu'on voit à teresinosaurus
c'est mais de quoi ça servait c'est
griffes gigantesques la réponse
généralement apportée étant que ça
devait servir à de manière similaire au
griffes surdimensionnés des
paresseux et notamment des paresseux
géants ça devait servir à attraper les
branches d'arbres pour les ramener à la
bouche
et se nourrir mais ou effeuiller les
branches d'arbres Suisse aurait pu
servira ça pourquoi pas mais bref on est
on n'est pas sûr de ce à quoi ça servait
ces griffes de Terry dinosaures et donc
ils ont fait des modélisations 3D
sur lesquels de ces griffes sur lesquels
ils ont appliqué une une analyse en
élément fini ce qui est en gros des
analyses biomécaniques pour voir les
niveaux de stress
se appliqués par les différents usages
de ces griffes donc par exemple là ils
ont testé le perçage donc en appliquant
une force donc sur les modèles 3D ils
appliquent de façon numérique sur
ordinateur une force sur la pointe de la
griffe donc c'est ce qu'ils appellent le
persing le perçage vous avez huken pool
donc c'est le c'est basiquement attraper
un truc et le ramener vers soi donc là
le hook and pool c'est une simulation de
d'un territinosaures qui ramènerait ils
ont testé ça sur plein de théropodes
évidemment pas ce que sur les stéries
dinosaures mais ce qui les intéresse
vraiment c'est les terres dinosaures des
alvaraisoïdes donc là ils ont simulé le
hook and pool qui est attrapé tiré le
donc le fait de ramener vers soi des
branches d'arbres par exemple et le
scratch digging donc là au lieu
d'appliquer la force au bout ils ont
appliqué la force juste en dessous du
bout de la griffe donc le scratch
diggins c'est ce que font les oreilles
par exemple ils creusent voilà c'est le
fait de creuser utiliser ces griffes
pour creuser donc on a là tous les
modèles 3D des griffes de théropodes et
notamment de thé rising ozoridés en
violet et d'Alva resoridés en rouge et
toutes ces griffes de théropodes ont
subi toutes ces toutes ces simulations
ces trois types de simulations
et en gros il y a deux choses qui
ressortent assez assez évidemment
la première c'est le scratch digging le
avec le scratch digging vous voyez que
le rouge apparaît très facilement sur le
bout des griffes de nos théropodes et
quand c'est rouge ça veut dire qu'il y a
beaucoup de stress et beaucoup de stress
c'est pas bon ça casse donc quand on
fait du scratch digging donc quand on
fait du creusage du quand on est quand
on fait du fouissage avec des griffes de
théropodes ça ne marche pas ça ne marche
pas globalement c'est pas des griffes
qui sont faites pour creuser parce que
on a très facilement vous voyez des
points rouges qui apparaissent à part
chez lianco
donc c'est ces fameuses Allevard
resorides pour lesquelles on pense
qu'ils utilisaient leur grosse griffes
épaisse leur seule et unique grosse
griffe épaisse pour creuser les
termitières
donc ça a l'air d'aller dans le sens de
d'un régime de
termitophage chez C enfin miremecophage
normalement on dit ça s'applique au
théâtre aussi bien au thermite
qu'aux fourmis donc un régime
mirmécophage irait bien du coup pour ce
pour ces deux-là qui sont à peu près les
deux seuls théropodes pour lesquels le
scratch digging ne pose n'a pas l'air de
poser de problème sur la simulation et
vous avez la deuxième chose à remarquer
c'est que les terresinosauridés et
surtout theresinosaurus qui a les
griffes les plus grandes de celles
observées dans cette étude
Therizinosaurus il pue la merde à tout
faire
[Rires]
il y a du rouge partout sur tes
résinosaurus même comparé à ses petits
cousins même comparé à un autre
terrizine aux oreidés de terres
Dinosaurus il y a rien qui marche avec
lui le piercing le il peut pas percer ça
ça foutou ça fout c'est griffant l'air
il peut pas tirer ça fout ses griffes en
l'air et il peut pas creuser ça fout ses
griffes en l'air d'après cette
simulation
et donc bah à quoi devait servir les
griffes de terizinosaurus si elle
servait ni à percer donc certainement
pas à se battre Jurassic World numéro 3
c'est toi que je regarde c'est toi que
je regarde là avec ton terizinosaure bon
on va pas dire du mal encore une fois de
Jurassic World 3 mais il le mérite
non il pouvait pas savoir cet article
est sorti après Jurassic World 3 il
pouvait pas savoir il pouvait pas ça
mais bref c'est toi que je regarde quand
même donc il pouvait pas percer donc il
pouvait pas se battre il pouvait pas
tirer donc ça servait pas à se nourrir
de la façon dont on croyait que ça
servait encore une fois l'hypothèse
dominante c'était il utilisait ses
griffes pour ramener les branches vers
lui apparemment ça marche pas non plus
et il peut pas creuser non plus avec ses
grandes griffes alors qu'est-ce qu'il
fait avec ses griffes bah l'article nous
propose que de façon pas très originale
mais bon il reste que ça une fois qu'on
a qu'on a enlevé toutes les hypothèses
plausibles bah il nous propose que
Therizinosaurus utilisait ses griffes
surtout à des fins
décorative
[Rires]
et on peut pas faire l'hypothèse d'une
fonction si on a exclu toutes les autres
fonctions on peut pas faire l'hypothèse
d'une fonction qui n'existe pas c'est
c'est anti scientifique faire
l'hypothèse d'une fonction qui n'existe
plus aujourd'hui c'est anti scientifique
parce que de toute façon vous ne pourrez
pas tester cette cette possibilité
peut-être que theresinosaurus faisait
que des revers de la main oui vous savez
c'était un tennisman à revers et
peut-être qu'en appliquant une force sur
le revers de la griffe on pourrait voir
si oui ou non il y résiste mais qui fait
ça aujourd'hui aucun animal ne fait ça
aujourd'hui donc ça rend l'hypothèse
très difficile à tester pas forcément
complètement non testables puisque je
viens de vous donner un moyen de la
tester mais ça rendrait l'hypothèse très
difficilement testable donc ouais
peut-être que Terry Dinosaurus faisait
que des revers de la main exclusivement
pour pour se défendre par exemple mais
en tout cas ça c'est le principe
d'actualisme c'est vraiment le c'est
l'outil le plus puissant de la
paléontologie mais c'est aussi le seul
outil qu'on a en réalité
et donc à partir du moment où vous
sortez des limites du principe de
l'actualisme donc par exemple en disant
oui mais non mais tes innosaurus ça
devait être une fonction qui n'existe
pas enfin qui n'existe plus bah oui mais
une fonction qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui c'est en dehors de du chant
du principe de actualisme donc en dehors
du champ des hypothèses est stables
donc vous êtes en train de faire de
l'anticien en disant ça
donc il vaut mieux en fait donc
l'explication tout ça pour dire que
l'explication c'était probablement pour
de la parade sexuelle bah elle est en
fait elle est pas si conne que ça c'est
juste que bah oui quand il reste plus
rien d'autre il reste la parade sexuelle
et c'est très cohérent avec le ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui du coup les plumes de
Pan évidemment un organe surdimensionné
qui ne sert absolument à rien qui est
même un problème en soi mais qui sert à
la parade sexuelle uniquement les bois
dessert les bois des serres c'est une
c'est une aberration physiologique c'est
un c'est un c'est un drame qui se
déroule chaque saison de reproduction
sous nos yeux des animaux qui chaque
année vous imaginez c'est des animaux
qui chaque année
créent un nouvel organe dont ils savent
déjà qu'ils vont le perdre à la fin de
l'année
enfin même pas à la fin de la saison de
repro chaque année vous créez un nouvel
organe vous générez vous investissez une
énergie colossale une quantité d'os qui
est foutu là-dedans qui ne sert à rien à
rien d'autre qu'à montrer c'est moi qui
est la plus grosse c'est moi le boss
c'est moi le plus c'est moi le et c'est
de la folie c'est de la folie faut vous
imager il faut vous représenter que les
serres il y en a même pas 5% qui se
reproduisent en réalité c'est le l'idée
c'est que chaque année vous avez un
millier de des milliards de Serge je
sais pas combien il y en a dans le monde
vous avez des milliers des millions de
serres qui qui génèrent des bois qui ne
vont servir à rien parce qu'il ne se
reproduiront pas il y a que 5% des
serres qui se reproduisent
tous les autres on se sont fait chier à
avoir des bois qui ont grandi qui ont
pompé du jus dans leur réserve d'énergie
qui ont qui ont en plus tiré du
phosphate de calcium de leurs eaux parce
qu'ils font une ostéoporose évidemment
parce qu'il faut bien qu'il faut bien
que cet OS là qui forme les boîtes
serres parce que ça s'appelle des bois
mais c'est pas du bois c'est de l'os
faut bien que cette os qui fait les bois
de serre viennent de quelque part alors
oui ils arrivent à rogner un os par ci
par-là pour essayer de récupérer du
phosphate de calcium mais ce phosphate
de calcium en réalité il vient de leur
zoo surtout donc ils développent une
ostéoporose formidable au point que
beaucoup meurent juste de fin parce que
ils n'ont plus ils n'ont plus assez
d'énergie pour continuer
et tout ça pourquoi pour se reproduire
et donc moi je trouve pas ça aberrant de
dire que les terres dinosaures leurs
griffes devaient être pas loin de ça
c'est à dire un organe surdimensionné
qui n'a qu'une seule et unique fonction
fonction montrer que c'est toi le
bossent montrer que c'est toi le plus
balaise et à l'occasion peut-être qu'il
s'en servait pour se battre mais il faut
rappeler que les organes comme les bois
des serres par exemple leur première
fonction c'est d'être le plus grand
possible pour montrer que vous êtes le
Patron c'est à dire que les le cerf le
cerf qui allait plus grands bois n'a pas
d'intérêt à se battre avec d'autres
serres et de remettre en jeu son titre
avec d'autres serres et les serres qui
ont des plus petits bois et qui viennent
défier le cerf au Grand Bois n'ont pas
plus de raison d'aller se battre contre
le grand cerf qui de le sert au Grand
Bois parce que de toute façon c'est
grand bois indique qu'ils vont lui
mettre qu'il va lui mettre la misère
donc il va y avoir le moins de combat
possible
d'où d'ailleurs et du coup ça va assez
bien cette explication évolutive va
assez bien avec le fait que ces griffes
ne sont bonnes à rien
ces griffes ne sont bonnes à rien elles
sont bonnes à être montrées et à montrer
que vous êtes le Patron
et à l'occasion vous allez vous battre
avec de façon très ritualisée comme le
font tous les animaux qui ont des grands
organes qui servent à se battre ils vont
se battre de façon très ritualisée il va
y avoir une danse il va y avoir une
démonstration d'abord et seulement si la
démonstration ne marche toujours pas à
dissuader l'un ou l'autre des
belligérants alors il y aura combat et
là il y a risque là il y a danger il y a
des serres qui meurent chaque année
pendant les combats ou des suites des
blessures engendrées par les combats
donc là il y a risque de péter vos
griffes mais ça vient seulement
longtemps après après après avoir juste
jaugé la taille des griffes de votre
adversaire et après le toute la danse
ritualisée et il faut bien s'imaginer
que les terres dinosaures étant des
manières raptoriens il y avait
probablement des danses ritualisées
puisque ils sont proches des oiseaux et
que les oiseaux évidemment sont très
connus pour leur
pour leur rituel de reproduction leur
paramuciale et si vous voulez en savoir
plus évidemment je vous mets l'article
comme tous les autres dans la
description on reste chez les théropodes
et maintenant on passe au teropode
préféré des tout-petits les spinosaures
idées donc là on s'intéresse pas à
Spinosaurus d'ailleurs on va
s'intéresser à Baryonyx et ceratosucus
des chercheurs britanniques et
américains se sont intéressés au cerveau
de ces spinosaures idées Baryonyx et
ceratosucus donc ce sont des spinosaures
idées de Grande-Bretagne et il se ils
ont découvert que le cerveau des
spinosauridés n'avait absolument rien de
spécial
voilà
j'avais envie de je voulais juste envie
j'avais juste envie de dire cette phrase
le cerveau des spinosaures idées est
chiant comme la mort il y a rien à voir
circuler il est d'une banalité
affligeante pour le cerveau d'un terreau
pote d'un dinosaure théropode de manière
générale il y a rien de spécial
contrairement au cerveau de
Tyrannosaurus qui a deux trois
spécificités comme par exemple le
cerveau de Tyrannosaurus a des olfacts
des bulb olfactifs gigantesques et un
tout petit lobboculaire bon bah non là
le plus populaire il est de taille
normale les labolfactif bon là ils les
ont pas donc en tout cas je crois pas
qu'ils les ont peut-être pour un des
deux ouais pour celui-là voilà les
lobolfactifs vous voyez sur sur Serato
suchus ils sont là ils sont bien son
normaux tout est normal tout va bien le
cerveau est pas spécialement grand il
est pas spécialement petit
ils sont chiants les spinosaures idées
ont un cerveau chiant
et donc l'article est vendu sur le fait
que
bah c'est des spinosaures idées le crâne
est tellement déformé chez les
spinosauridés qu'on s'attendait quand
même à ce que le cerveau soit un peu
déformé mais non en fait le cerveau est
super chiant big up gros gros big up à
jameside Maxisciences qui a quand même
réussi à faire ce titre ce qui je sais
pas il est faux a tellement de niveau
que c'est n'importe quoi un tellement de
niveau
que j'ai du mal à rester poli quand j'en
parle le cerveau de ce dinosaure
carnivore de Jurassic Park bientôt
recréé par des scientifiques non mais
vous êtes sérieux
c'est tu t'imagines enfin je vais faire
un titre qui va suggérer aux gens qu'on
va mettre recréer tu sais dans une
espèce de jarre de forme dans un tube à
essai on va recréer le cerveau d'un
dinosaure je vais faire un titre qui
suggère ça c'est quel niveau de
journaliste scientifique ça sérieusement
c'est
je vais faire un titre complètement fou
mais qui va mettre dans la tête des gens
l'idée qui a des scientifiques fous qui
vont recréer le cerveau d'un dinosaure
dans une boîte de Pétri ouais ça me
paraît bien suivant et on termine avec
les dinos non on termine pas encore on
termine avec les théropodes on termine
avec les dinosaures théropodes avec cet
article sorti dans la revue allemande
the science of nature
n'a tout revisse Uncharted
qui est publié par le docteur Anderson
et qui nous dit en fait en gros que il y
a des contraintes morphologiques qui
s'appliquent à l'évoluer enfin
l'évolution de la taille chez les
dinosaures théropodes en un mot
commençant ça veut dire qu'en fait il
existe une taille limite chez les
dinosaures théropodes enfin en tout cas
c'est ce que suggère cet article il
existe une taille limite et cette taille
limite elle est contrainte par le fait
que vous pouvez pas agrandir votre
bassin indéfiniment votre bassin c'est
un point d'insertion pour les muscles
qui servent à faire bouger vos jambes et
en fait il y a un moment où le volume de
vos jambes donc c'est la loi des des
cubes et des carrés il y a un moment où
le volume de muscle dans vos jambes va
de très très loin excéder la surface
accessible sur le bassin pour qu'il se
pour que ses muscles s'attachent
donc à un moment où le bassin il y aura
plus assez de surface ou alors les
muscles sont tellement paquets que ça va
créer des contraintes trop gigantesques
du coup ça impose une taille limite à un
dinosaure parce que vos jambes au bout
d'un moment faut qu'elle vous propulse
il faut que vous puissiez bouger ça
c'est un article qui nous rappelle que
ça reste des machines biologiques
soumises à des lois physiques et que ces
lois physiques vous pouvez pas les les
contorsionner à l'infini faudrait
peut-être être un peu plus prudent sur
nos estimations de longueur et donc
l'accélération était déjà très fortement
réduite chez des animaux de 11 12 mètres
comme Tyrannosaurus avec une
accélération qui aurait qui aurait été
plus alors je crois qu'il le dit là mais
en gros une accélération qui aurait été
moins de 10% ce qui n'aurait été que
moins de 10% de celle des plus petites
formes des plus petits des plus petits
animaux vous imaginez il reste plus que
10% de l'accélération dans les que les
plus petits dans les plus petits
dinosaures étaient capables
chez un Tyrannosaurus donc le
Tyrannosaurus ça devait être une
usine à gaz au démarrage d'où d'ailleurs
l'idée que si il chassait il chassait en
embûches en embuscade et on termine avec
les dinosaures avec un ankylosaure Pina
colorus grangeri qui nous vient du
désert de Gobi et qui est le premier
dinosaure à préserver
les organes vocaux donc le larynx je
vous montre une petite reconstruction
juste ici vous voyez donc là voilà où le
la chose aurait été située et comment
elle aurait été orientée chez l'animal
vivant vous voyez c'est larynx quoi avec
des plaques des plaques Lary qu'on
retrouve habituellement chez les
archosor et là où c'est intéressant en
fait c'est que l'analyse de ces plaques
la rageale montre certaines similitudes
avec les oiseaux alors on est encore
très très loin d'un syrinx on est très
très loin du syrin que les oiseaux leur
organe vocal surtout les oiseaux qui
chantent en réalité mais tous les
oiseaux ont un local qui s'appelle le
sirinx et qui permet de faire des sons
extrêmement complexes
notre ankylosaure il a pas ça il a pas
un sirex on s'enflamme pas le plus vieux
syrinx connu c'est vegavis qui est déjà
orienté sur la voie canard de la force
donc c'est déjà un truc très dérivé et
il vient du Crétacé mais là notre
tranquillosaure il a pas ça il a pas un
cyrinthe il a un organe vocal alors qui
est suffisamment différent de celui d'un
crocodile pour dire qu'il pouvait
produire des vocalisations plus
sophistiquées qu'un crocodile mais il
est loin d'être aussi dérivé que celui
d'un d'un
oiseau donc il pouvait produire des
vocalisations certes mais c'est pas non
plus il pouvait pas chanter voilà mais
en tout cas c'est la première fois qu'on
démontre qu'un dinosaure non navien
pouvait produire des vocalisations
laryngée donc pas seulement vous savez
des gros gros
comme on voit certains reptiles faire
vous voyez pas pas des pincements des
couinements qui sortent ou qui sortent
de la gorge mais vous savez des
grognements guturo là
on Sande où on sent qu'il y a des
glaires qui remuent en même temps oui
non non là ce sont c'est une vraie voix
en gros il y a une voix alors est-ce que
ça veut dire que le T-Rex rugissait
parce que c'est évidemment ce qu'on va
me demander la réponse est non
probablement pas encore une fois le
rugissement c'est un truc qui est très
spécifique au Félia enfin au félidé de
la famille des Panthères donc c'est même
pas tous les fait l'idée c'est juste les
panthétiner à savoir les grands chats
Lyon tigre etc donc c'est très
spécifique le rugissement comme truc
c'est pas un truc que tout le monde peut
faire et certainement pas un dinosaure
donc est-ce que ça veut dire que les
dinosaures pouvaient de la voix
pouvaient donner de la voix oui ça doit
pouvoir le dire ce qu'il y a
d'intéressant c'est que chez les
ankylosaures on avait déjà repéré ce
système dans le dans leur tête à ce
niveau-là ils ont ils ont le les
conduits nasaux qui font des boucles
et ça c'est vachement bizarre ça a pas
besoin de faire des boucles à conduit
nasale au contraire un conduit nasal
plus chez droit mieux vous respirer
généralement donc du coup pareil c'est
boucles dans le combinasal ça suggérait
qu'ils étaient capables de produire des
sons avec leurs conduits azo donc des
sons qui ressemblent rien un peu
vous voyez donc si vous si vous vous
empêchez vous essayez de faire remuer
vos vos narines c'est très très dur pour
nous nous on est toujours obligé
d'utiliser notre larynx pour produire
des sons mais
parce qu'on peut pas faire autrement
mais du coup chez les dinosaures jusqu'à
présent on pensait qu'il ne pouvait que
utiliser des sons très gutturaux donc
voilà des remuages de gorges un peu un
peu gargouillis
comme les crocodiles ou bien des sons
nasaux qui étaient produits comme par
exemple chez l'ankylosaure dans ses
boucles que faisaient les conduits d'azo
donc ou comme les parasolophus par
exemple parasolophus c'est avec le les
naseaux les conduits nasaux pareil ils
font une boucle dans la Crète jusque
jusqu'en haut de la crête puis
redescendre dans le les dans les trous
du nez donc pareil ça ça devait produire
des sons mais c'est des sons nasaux à
rien à voir avec des sons laryngés donc
là on a la première preuve de son
laryngée une voix il y a une voix ils
avaient une voix qu'est-ce qui faisait
avec cette voix on peut pas le savoir
avec juste quelques quelques petits
ossements ça c'est certain mais ils
avaient une voix il pouvait donner de la
voix par contre c'est pas assez Rex donc
chanter déjà tous les oiseaux avec des
syracs ne chantent pas
c'est très spécifique au passé réformes
il y a vous avez les canards par exemple
ça ne chante pas mais donc le syrac il
n'en n'ont pas c'est dinosaure non
naviens en tout cas en tout cas ça ce
n'est pas un sirex donc il ne pouvait
pas chanter c'est pas la peine de
commencer à vous imaginer des dinosaures
qui chantent c'est pas parce qu'ils ont
une voix qu'ils chantent mais par contre
ça ça devait avoir une fonction et
probablement encore une fois une
fonction d'alerte une fonction de une
fonction dans la parade nuptiale surtout
s'ils avaient aussi un équipement nasal
pour faire des sons c'est que c'est
qu'il devait y avoir une fonction
importante et quelle fonction plus
importante que celle de se reproduire
évidemment c'est la fonction la plus
importante en tout cas aux yeux de la
sélection naturelle
donc probablement encore une fois à
défaut de mieux un rôle dans la parade
nuptiale donner des alertes communiquer
entre les individus etc etc on reste
dans les trucs qui font donner de la
voix mais qui ont fait gueuler là pour
le coup et c'est évidemment cette image
cette image d'un représentant du
gravécien européen d'Europe de l'Ouest
avec le chapeau vous voyez de la Vénus
le fameux chapeau de la Vénus que vous
voyez qui est la Vénus de bassen pourri
basse en Pouille oui j'allais dire
j'avais la Vénus de Vilaine d'orf en
tête du coup pour moi ça allait être un
nom en allemand mais non c'est
apparemment c'est un nom français c'est
basse en Pouille bref vous voyez ce
chapeau de coquillages c'est le même que
celui de la Vénus et donc des analyses
génétiques qui nous montrent que en fait
nos ancêtres européens jusqu'à il y a au
moins 6000 ans et même moins que ça et
même encore moins que ça si vous êtes
britannique à la base parce que
évidemment ils ont mis plus longtemps à
atteindre
les îles britanniques nos ancêtres
jusqu’il y a au moins 6000 ans en Europe
de l'ouest ils avaient cette tête là ce
qui est pas hyper cohérent d'ailleurs
avec le
l'article qui est attaché à cette image
que je vous montre là qui a été publié
dans nightcher nightcher lui-même qui
est une nouvelle analyse génétique des
peuples européens et de leurs ancêtres
grâce à de nouvelles de nouveaux
échantillons qui ont été obtenus sur des
restes archéologiques du grave et si
justement
donc c'est pas hyper cohérent parce
qu'en fait il a les yeux foncés alors
que dans alors que là-dedans dans
l'article ils nous disent ils avaient
les yeux clairs ils avaient la peau
foncée mais ils avaient les yeux clairs
et ça à la limite ce qu'il y a
d'intéressant en fait avec cet article
ce que je voulais surtout vous montrer
c'est surtout c'est pas seulement la
photo qu'ils ont attachée mais c'est
surtout en fait il y a un chat il y a un
paragraphe dans l'article lui-même qui
est spécifiquement dédié à la question
à la question voilà du phénotype voilà
donc la question du phénotype c'est à
dire la question de la couleur de peau
donc c'est là où il nous disent cash ils
avaient une couleur de donc ils avaient
ils étaient pas adaptés à la digérer la
lactase ils avaient une couleur de peau
foncé donc ça doit être de ce côté-là
qu'il le dise une couleur de peau foncé
et ils avaient les yeux clairs et donc
c'est à partir de 6000 ans quand ils ont
commencé à se faire remplacer par les
nouvelles populations
venue notamment d'Europe de l'Est et du
d'Europe de l'Est enfin venu d'Europe de
l'Est mais qui elle-même venait en
réalité du Croissant fertile donc c'est
la révolution néolithique
ces nouvelles populations du néolithique
quand elles sont venues envahir l'Europe
en fait ont ramené de nouveaux variants
et notamment les variants avec la peau
plus claire
hérité ou pas de Néandertal puisque
évidemment ces populations comme celle
d'Europe était hybrides Néandertal ce
n'est pas dit dans l'article est-ce que
le la révolution néolithique aussi a
joué un rôle dans l'apparition de ces
variants plus clair c'est une hypothèse
mais pareil c'est pas discuter dans
l'article donc voilà jusqu'à il y a
14000 ans enfin jusqu'à il y a 6000 ans
en gros les Européens de l'Ouest ils
avaient la peau sombre les yeux
relativement clairs et du coup on pense
qu'il devait ressembler raisonnablement
à ça et ça c'est quand même super
intéressant et puis il y a d'autres
choses évidemment dans cet article il
n'y a pas que ça vous avez vu c'est
juste un petit paragraphe de tout
l'article ce que j'aime c'est qu'il y a
un paragraphe qui est vraiment dédié à
ça mais la grande question de cet
article c'est surtout la question de la
survie des populations graves etiennes
et de la transition vers le Magdalénien
la survie de ces populations
gravéciennes pendant le dernier maximum
glaciaire et là où c'est intéressant en
fait c'est que il constate qu'il s'est
passé un drame en Italie
c'est que là où on pensait qu'en fait
durant si vous regardez une carte si
vous regardez une carte en gros les
glaciers ils arrivent du Nord et on
pensait que la péninsule ibérique la
péninsule italienne et les Balkans avait
servi de refuge à ces populations graves
Etienne donc ces cultures gravissiennes
sont devenus le solutréa pendant la le
dernier maximum glaciaire ce sont
redispersés et ont transitionné vers le
magdalenia du moins ça ce qu'est ce que
moi et mon background de pas archéologue
je rappelle que je ne suis pas
archéologue je suis pas léontologue tout
ça c'est à peine des fossiles pour moi
si vous pouvez en tirer de l'ADN c'est
pas
c'est pas mon truc mais bref j'essaye de
vous retranscrire ça tel que moi je le
comprends donc vous avez ces populations
gravissiennes qui se sont retrouvées
isolées en Espagne en Italie dans les
Balkans parce que les glaciers les ont
poussé vers le bas et donc génétiquement
on s'attend à ce que à retrouver en fait
ces trois isolat dans les gènes des
populations modernes et des fossiles
qu'on retrouve de cette époque
dans le coin vous voyez que tous ces
points là que vous voyez sur ces cartes
ce sont des fossiles donc des fossiles
il y a 9000 ans des fossiles il y a 8000
ans des fossiles liés à 7000 ans et des
fossiles de moins de 7000 ans donc moins
de 7000 ans là on est déjà bien envahi
par les par les grands remplaçants de la
Mésopotamie avec leur néolithique donc
et là en fait ce qu'ils ont vu bah c'est
quand en fait il s'est passé un drame en
Italie c'est que effectivement les
gravésiens se sont dispersés vers le sud
de l'Italie et ce que vous voyez en fait
c'est que plus ça devient rouge et plus
les et plus la diversité génétique
devient faible vous voyez la diversité
génétique qui dégringol qui dégringol
qui dégringole jusqu'au point ou ce
qu'ils disent dans l'article c'est qu'il
y avait plus que 70 individus
reproducteurs dans la population ça veut
pas dire qu'ils étaient que 70 mais il y
en a que 70 qui effectivement étaient
reproducteur
et donc ça ça donne le scénario et donc
calquer sur les dates qu'on a pour ces
individus là en fait on constate que les
plus vieux sont au nord de l'Italie et
les plus jeunes sont au sud de l'Italie
et que pendant le dernier maximum
glacière en gros vous avez cette ce
recul de la population dans la péninsule
ibérique mais en fait ce recul s'est
accompagné d'une réduction beaucoup trop
drastique de la population et cette
population pardon cette population
d'Italie pas ibérique italique je sais
pas si on dit italique bref cette
population là qui qui a survécu dans
dans en Sicile s'est éteinte
et donc elle a pas recontribué en fait à
la rediversification du solutréa
et quand arriver le solutréat vous avez
en gros deux populations une sortie
probablement d'Espagne mais peut-être
pourquoi pas des Balkans ils ont pas
suffisamment du style d'échantillons
pour savoir si c'est revenu des Balkans
mais en tout cas l'Espagne a joué un
rôle dans la repopulation en fait de
l'Europe mais pas l'Italie durant le
dernier maximum glaciaire et ce qu'ils
disent aussi c'est que dans la
structuration génétique des populations
en Europe est très intéressante parce
que vous avez vraiment les Bleus d'un
côté les rouges de l'autre séparer entre
entre des populations génétiques qui
visiblement ne se mélangez pas une en
Europe de l'Ouest et une en Europe de
l'Est donc ça c'est cet article je vous
le mets évidemment en description si
vous souhaitez lire c'est un peu velu
c'est beaucoup d'archéologie et beaucoup
de génétiques c'est un bel exemple de
multidisciplinarité mais aussi du coup
un bel exemple de comment la
multidisciplinarité ça rend les trucs
très difficiles à suivre
si vous êtes très bon en archéologie
mais pas en génétique vous êtes paumé si
vous êtes bon en génétique pas en
archéologie vous êtes paumé et si vous
êtes comme moi ben vous êtes mauvais
dans les deux donc
on
reste avec les hominidés mais alors là
on repart très très loin dans le temps
nous sommes en 50 avant Jésus-Christ et
bien avant ça non on est il y a 3
millions d'années on est il y a 3
millions d'années 3 millions d'années on
a même pas encore les premiers
représentants du genre Homo par contre
ce qu'on aille à 3 millions d'années ce
sont les premiers choppers les premiers
chopper ou gale et aménagé en français
ou all du voyant pour le terme technique
les premiers galets aménagés hall du
voyage à 3 millions d'années
qui sont associés à un chico de
parenthropus et ça c'est intéressant
parce que si on a du galet aménagé avec
du pain tropus bah ça veut dire que
c'est pas homo qui a inventé les
premiers outils et ça c'est très
intéressant parce que on avait déjà du
coup des
outils encore plus primitifs qui ont été
associés avec kenyanthropus qui est lui
non plus pas représentant des du genre
homo qui datait de 3,2 3,3 millions
d'années et en Afrique du Sud on avait
beaucoup on a beaucoup beaucoup de
grottes dans lesquelles on a une
association très nette entre de l'OL du
voyant et des parents trop puces mais
plus jeunes de l'ordre de 2 millions
d'années donc on avait déjà en fait
cette association parenthropus outils
hall du voyage mais à 2 millions
d'années là on est en Afrique de l'Est
et on a ces zones du voyage aussi
associé à des restes maigrichons mais
existants de parenthropus à 3 millions
d'années donc ça semble aller dans le
sens de ce qu'on voyait déjà en Afrique
du Sud à savoir que l'utilisation
d'outils et ce qu'on avait pu voir aussi
avec Kenny anthropus à savoir que
l'utilisation d'outils n'est pas la
panade du genre Homo
rappelez-vous que Homo habilis à la base
s'appelle habilis parce que normalement
l'utilisation de l'outil est censée être
l'apanage du genre Homo évidemment c'est
une définition des années 70
rappelez-vous qu'une définition du genre
homo qui n'est pas philogénétique de
toute façon
n'a pas beaucoup de valeur
biologiquement on fait un grand voyage
dans le temps maintenant on va retourner
dans le permis à moyen on est à
260 millions d'années là on est plus on
touche plus à des trucs là qui sont à
peine des fossiles là à 3 millions
d'années là de quoi me parlez-vous non
là on va parler les vrais les bons
fossiles la plus vieux que les
dinosaures eux-mêmes les thérapsides du
Permien oui madame
l'Afrique du Sud une fois de plus dans
Journal of vertebreate paléontologie des
collègues qui me sont chers ont publié
un nouveau fragment un fragment de d'os
d'un numerus donc ce bout là de
l'humérus la tête qui s'articule avec
l'épaule normalement c'est ce que vous
voyez à l'écran
et ce fragment d'humérus bah il est très
intéressant parce que quand on le
compare un pélicosaure du genre de
Dimetrodon et un thérapie de comme un
bière musculaire par exemple bah en fait
il ne correspond ni à l'un ni à l'autre
mais se trouve assez intermédiaire dans
sa morphologie
et ça ça c'est hyper intéressant donc
c'est mon collègue Luc Norton l'un des
co-auteurs qui a trouvé ce fragment il y
a quasiment 10 ans jour pour jour
maintenant enfin il y a 10 ans quasiment
jour pour jour et en fait ouais les
caractéristiques de ce fragment
d'humérus c'est un gros fragments et il
tient dans la main donc c'est un gros
animal c'était probablement un gros
carnivore
c'est un gros carnivore parce que tous
les pélicosor et tous les thérapies de
bazo sont des carnivores donc c'est une
extrapolation que je vous fais là mais
c'était probablement quand même un assez
gros carnivore et alors depuis presque
150 ans qu'on cherche des fossiles en
Afrique du Sud c'est en 2013 qu'on
découvre enfin une preuve que ce machin
a existé et en plus et ce machin semble
être intermédiaire entre les pélicosor
et les thérapies donc vous avez
vous avez ce chaînon manquant là qui se
balade dans le permis moyen et ça fait
250 ans qu'on passe à côté et on se
demande où il est on se demande ce que
c'est et honnêtement ça fait partie de
ces ça fait partie de ces découvertes
qu'on ne s'attend pas à faire en fait on
s'attend pas encore aujourd'hui à
découvrir un possible grand carnivore
dans le permis à moyen qu'on ne
connaîtrait pas déjà et encore plus si
ce machin devrait être intermédiaire
entre les pélicosor et les thérapies
parce que en Afrique du Sud on a
beaucoup de thérapies en Amérique du
Nord ils ont exclusivement des pélicosor
mais entre les deux on n'a pas
normalement
vous voyez c'est ça le truc c'est c'est
ce qui s'appelle le
l'intervalle d'olsson l'intervalle
d'olsson c'est ce morceau du registre
fossile qui nous manque en fait entre
les derniers pélicosor et les premiers
thérapsides je simplifie évidemment il y
a encore des pélicosaures au moment où
les thérapies de son vivant mais ce sont
des groupes tellement barrés comme les
caséidés ou les varanopidés que on est à
peu près sûr que c'est pas eux les
ancêtres des thérapies
vous avez cette intervalle dans le sol
entre les deux ou la transition la
transformation des pélicosor en
thérapied a eu lieu et on en a pas les
fossiles et ben là bim
ce fossile là nous montre qu'il était
sous notre pif depuis 150 ans ça fait 10
ans que Luc Norton l'a trouvé c'est
seulement maintenant qu'on l'étudie et
qu'on se rend compte que merde en fait
faut qu'on cherche plus faut qu'on
cherche mieux faut qu'on cherche
ailleurs je sais pas ce qu'il faut qu'on
cherche mais il faut qu'on cherche
parce que là on a on a loupé on a loupé
le 10 métro don sud-africain quoi c'est
littéralement ça quoi on a loupé un
machin de la taille d'un Dimetrodon qui
aurait dû se balader en Afrique du Sud
et où il est où il est bon et ben va
falloir le chercher oui madame oui
madame on reste dans le Permien toujours
cette fois dans le Permien inférieur de
Russie avec une très belle découverte
publiée dans biology later letters qui
est un très grand journal très journal
très prestigieux où ils ont trouvé des
insectes alors la famille des insectes
c'est un nom un peu à coucher dehors
c'est les poly poly polynéopéra donc
j'imagine que ça vient de pollen et de
néoptère donc la nouvelle elle a pollen
probablement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je mon latin grec mon latin slash
grec est inexistant mais bref c'est
polynéopéra ils ont trouvé des fossiles
des fossiles très très bien préservés
qui une fois regardé au microscope voyez
on petit grain et ses petits grains une
fois analysés s'avère être des fragments
de pollen ils avaient des fragments de
pollen coincés sur la tête sur les poils
de la tête sur les poils du thorax et
sur les poils de l'abdomen et il y en a
pas qu'un en plus il y en a plein ils en
ont trouvé plein des comme ça avec des
petits des petits paquets de pollen
comme ça colle à eux et le mieux c'est
que il y a pas qu'une espèce de pollen
il y en a trois en réalité donc vous
voyez il y a ça c'est la liste des
spécimens vous voyez qu'il y a quand
même une bonne poignée de spécimens
d'insectes polynéoptère qui ont ces sacs
de pollen coincé sur eux et c'est sacs
de pollen contiennent eux-mêmes trois
espèces différentes donc on est vraiment
sur les premiers insectes pollinisateurs
au début du Permien donc qui visitait
comme ça plusieurs plantes et emporter
des petits paquets de pollen les seuls
qu'ils ont pu enfin
ils arrivent à avoir trois catégories de
pollen différents le ceux qu'ils ont le
mieux identifié ça appartient à des
plantes qui s'appellent des corbeilles
des cordes donc c'est ce que vous voyez
reconstituer ici et du coup ça veut dire
que bah il visitait ses plantes se
couvrait de pollen exactement comme les
insectes d'aujourd'hui et aller comme ça
de fleurs en fait de pas fleur en plein
fleurs parce que on est au Père mien il
y a pas de fleurs et c'est ça qui est en
fait qui est ouf avec ça c'est que vous
avez l'origine des insectes
pollinisateurs genre
100 millions d'années avant l'origine de
la première planta fleurs parce que là
on est on est au permis inférieur la
première planta fleurs c'est pas avant
le Jurassique l'origine de la de la
pollinisation et de l'interaction
symbiotique entre insectes et plantes
pour la pollinisation
entre les abeilles et les plantes à
fleurs tout ça tout ça vous la prenez
cette histoire vous la emballez
gentiment et puis vous la balancez à la
poubelle parce que bam c'est faux cils
là il faut tout par terre la revue PNS
très prestigieuse revue nous propose une
étude des trilobites tenez puisqu'on
parlait tout à l'heure avec les Terriens
isinosauridé on parlait justement là de
ces structures stupidement gigantesques
qui ne pouvait servir que à faire de la
démonstration de force pendant les
rituels et les parades nuptiales bah
voilà
on passe maintenant au trilobite de
cette famille ici particulière qui ont
un trident sur leur tête alors cette
famille elle s'appelle enfin c'est pas
une famille c'est un genre ça s'appelle
les valisérops les valises les
trilobites du genre vallisérops donc ils
sont connus pour avoir un trident sur le
pif et notamment les plus dérivés vous
voyez qu'ils avaient un trident même
monté sur fourchette à ce niveau-là qui
peut atteindre des longueurs assez
ridicule donc dans cet article ils vont
nous proposer en fait que ce trident
était utilisé à des fins de à des fins
de de parade et notamment de combat
entre mal pour conquérir des femelles ou
au moins un des fins de démonstration
pour montrer que vous êtes évidemment le
plus fort et ne pas avoir à combattre et
alors là ils se sont basés sur ce qui
est à mon avis quelque chose de d'un peu
léger
c'est un petit peu léger en l'occurrence
c'est ce spécimen pathologique voilà
c'est leur seul et unique argument je
suis formel leur seul est unique
argument c'est ce spécimen pathologique
en fait il est pathologique parce qu'il
a quatre dents au lieu de 3 et du coup
il est pas symétrique du tout etc et du
coup eux ça leur fait dire que bah si il
a réussi à survivre aussi vieux donc
jusqu'à maturité avec un trident qui
était mal formé bah ça veut dire que le
trident ne servait pas à chercher de la
nourriture
ça veut dire que le trident n'avait pas
une fonction particulière
pour la survie de l'animal ça veut dire
que le trident aussi n'était pas non
plus un handicap gigantesque pour
l'animal et donc encore une fois tout ce
qui reste comme explication c'est
l'utilisation à des fins de
démonstration à des fins de montrer que
c'est vous le patron que c'est vous qui
avez le plus beau trident à la femelle
ou de montrer aux autres mâles avec leur
trident que votre tri dans il est bien
plus gros et que si tu veux te battre je
te retourne en 2 secondes voilà je te
rattrape avec ma fourchette et clique je
te retourne donc ça c'est un peu leur
seul et unique argument alors après il y
a toute une analyse morphométrique qui a
été faite qui qui a l'air très très très
très sophistiqué mais qui n'a pour
d'autres buts que de dire que le trident
de ces trilobites ressemble aux
structures qu'on voit chez certains
scarabées chez certains coléoptères
modernes c'est une façon très compliquée
de dire bah oui ça ressemble à ce qu'on
voit chez les scarabée moderne alors ça
devait fonctionner de la même façon avec
encore une fois ce petit bémol que j'ai
souligné ici
la structure n'est pas visiblement
dimorphique
ce qui est alors ce qui n'était pas un
problème avec theresinosaure un petit
peu plus tôt parce que theresinosaure on
en a pas trouvé tant que ça donc on va
je veux dire c'est difficile avec
seulement les fossiles qu'on a de quand
on parle de vertébrés on parle que de
quelques peut-être dizaines de fossiles
maximum
donc on parle pas de beaucoup de
fossiles avec les vertébrés avec
teresinosaures plus ils deviennent
grands et plus à bien compliqué en plus
donc avec les grands vertébrés comme
theresinosaures on n'a pas beaucoup de
fossiles donc on s'attend pas à voir un
dimorphisme entre mâle et femelle sur si
peu de matériel
voilà c'est pas une grosse surprise par
contre peut-être parce que on n'a pas
assez de matériel voilà c'est ça par
contre chez les trilobites on a beaucoup
de matériel et donc ne pas voir de
différence de entre mâle et femelles
chez le genre wallisérops
c'est c'est un peu plus problématique
parce que là on a un peu plus de
matériel en fait
il ne semble pas qu'il y ait de
différence mâle et femelle chez wallisé
robs alors est-ce que ça veut dire qu'on
a mis toutes les femelles dans une autre
espèce parce qu'elles sont tellement
différentes des mâles qu'on a pas réussi
à se rendre compte que c'était des
femelles peut-être ou bien peut-être
qu'il y avait effectivement pas de
dimorphisme et que peut-être du coup
cette structure n'était absolument pas
sexuelle ou bien les gènes qui code pour
cette structure étaient exprimée autant
chez les mâles que chez les femelles
c'est à dire que les femelles n'ont pas
le matériel génétique pour réprimer
l'expression de de strident
c'est une possibilité ça arrive chez
certains animaux modernes les mâles les
mâles ont effectivement des structures
sur développées pour se battre et pour
faire de la des démonstrations de force
mais du coup les mêmes les mêmes gènes
s'expriment aussi chez les femelles mais
simplement par effets secondaires en
fait c'est que chez les mâles ça
s'exprime de façon tellement forte que
les femelles n'ont pas le matériel
génétique pour réprimer l'expression
c'est intéressant comme j'ai dit on est
passé de on est passé quand même d'un
stade où web peut-être que c'était pour
la parade nuptiale ou peut-être que
c'était pour se battre avec les autres
mâles à ah bah maintenant on a des
arguments alors je les trouve un peu
faiblards les arguments mais ça c'est
que mon opinion probablement que des
spécialistes des trilobites vous diront
mais non c'est évident c'est évident bon
comme j'ai dit il y a pas grand monde à
la base je pense qu'il aurait remis ça
en question donc on est quand même sur
quelque chose qui fera consensus à mon
avis ça ça va pas ça va pas faire gros
débat et puis pour terminer avec avec
les invertébrés c'est vrai que j'ai même
pas sais même pas mentionné mais pour
une fois je fais de l'invertébré
donc c'est quand même pas mal tu vois je
fais des efforts donc pour terminer avec
les invertébrés je voulais juste vous
montrer c'est le site de
Montceau-les-Mines qui se trouve en
France du coup qui est un site du
Carbonifère et où on retrouve des
fossiles absolument extraordinaires et
donc cette équipe cette équipe donc oui
c'est surtout une équipe française mais
avec un petit peu d'allemand qui nous a
publié cet article sur
Montceau-les-Mines sur les myriapods
donc les mille-pattes de
Montceau-les-Mines conservé dans ces
magnifiques nodules vous voyez c'est du
très joli c'est très très belle
conservation de tissus mou notamment qui
sont préservés et alors regardez ils ont
passé ça dans des scanners à rayons X
regardez la finesse de cette
préservation regardez là ça c'est le
corps entier on voit toutes les pattes
on voit chaque plaque du corps qui est
préservée chaque chaque segment de
kitting qui est réservé et notamment
regarder la tête quoi regardez la tête
le détail de la tête de ce myriapode
comment s'est préservé ces deux-là folie
furieuse regardez c'est magnifique ils
en ont pas qu'un en plus ils en ont ils
en ont des dizaines c'est la jalousie
quoi la jalousie de la folie de comment
ils arrivent à segmenter à isoler chaque
chaque segment de la de la carapace de
kitting pour pour reconstituer la tête
c'est de la folie furieuse donc si ça
vous intéresse voilà c'était juste pour
vous montrer c'est les belles images là
là c'est purement les belles images il y
a évidemment de la bonne science
derrière mais je ne la comprends pas car
je ne suis pas un spécialiste au démeria
pas mais je vous invite à aller voir si
ça vous intéresse parce que c'est quand
même de la folie qu'on a des trucs comme
ça chez nous et que et que ça aurait été
ça aurait été honte de ma part que je
laisse passer un truc pareil sous le
radar quoi
et pour terminer tout court cette fois
avec avec tout et ben on va parler de
Bigfoot
un petit article de cryptoso pour
terminer et cet article qui a été publié
par par le Département des analyses
statistiques de Pittsburgh aux USA donc
cette personne flow Fox fun une petite
analyse tout en finesse tout en calme de
la distribution des des
occurrences de Bigfoot
et qui nous la compare avec l'occurrence
des l'occurrences des des ours et la
présence humaine et qui constate une
corrélation surpuissante
entre les trois et qui veut dire qu'en
gros bah plus curieusement plus il y a
d'ours et plus il y a de gens pour voir
les ours plus il y a de Bigfoot
cette chose que ça veut dire je trouve
ça je trouve ça en fait d'une simplicité
et
d'une satisfaction absolument
gigantesque c'est juste bah oui
évidemment oui évidemment
mais bien sûr enfin évidemment que c'est
pas magique
ben non c'est pas magique évidemment que
c'est pas surnaturel évidemment que
c'est pas Bigfoot évidemment que plus
vous avez de gens et plus vous avez de
plus vous avez d'ours noir en
l'occurrence c'est vraiment l'espèce
nord-américaine d'ours noir donc plus
vous avez deux personnes pour voir des
ours noirs et plus il y a d'ours noir et
plus vous avez de gens qui croivent voir
des Bigfoot c'est simple c'est clair
c'est limpide
que voulez-vous dire de plus et donc
c'est significatif puisque c'est le
département des analyses statistiques
qui le dit
voilà c'était Paléo news je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi abonnez-vous
pour ne rien manquer d'anciens et je
vous dis à très bientôt sur notre chaîne
salut
[Musique]